being unanimously liked and adored the
only person that I can think of that was
both wealthy and unanimously liked and
adored
was Dave Chappelle
and now that's gone yeah now he's a
polarizing figure but he was the last
one that I can look and be like wow
here's a person that had strong opinions
but both sides were supportive they
thought that he was absolutely hilarious
they want to go see his shows
and until the trans thing
yeah it's interesting who else is it
there's a mega star uh yeah yeah Kanye
was somewhat kind of like Tom Hanks yeah
I mean like Tom Hanks Keanu Reeves yeah
the completely apolitical figures
they don't uh take a stance that's the
best thing because I was thinking Warren
Buffett but he don't come out yeah I
drink though yeah I feel like Kanye
Gotta Throw out there so people like him
like I sit on a bench and I drink a Coke
you know the most annoying part of his
day is walking out of his Maybach and
then sitting on a stupid bench in Omaha
and then cracking a [ __ ] Coke and
sipping it so that they can take a
picture of it and post it to Instagram
so he can be like normal you don't
believe the story at all maybe he enjoys
what about the McDonald's do you believe
Patton Oswald's story when he was got a
picture taken of him writing his [ __ ]
eulogy or whatever it was for taking a
picture of Dave Chappelle do you believe
that was sincere and thoughtful and
no okay I'm gonna write this letter just
if you could just take a picture of it
is there a chance that he can actually
enjoy that
no what if he just said you enjoy it you
enjoy some simple things he can't break
routine maybe so maybe he's
superstitious and he's like yo these
these Cokes and McDonald's have made me
billions of dollars I can't break this
routine like a guy who got to wear his
lucky socks on game day
you see what we do with rich people
who does that you you wake up you look
at the sun because Superman told you
you've been doing it bro I haven't been
I can tell you've been saying no I'm
saying I'm missing the sun
I need sun but I'm just saying maybe
that's just like a thing that he likes
to do in his life like I can see there's
a world where it's [ __ ] and I can
see a world where it's like I he
actually may enjoy that
what do you think is more likely
honestly I'm going 50 50. no I don't
he's an old ass man like he what does he
want me a counter question what's more
fun to talk about on the podcast because
I I just realized
yeah I'm not saying that he's bad for it
what I'm saying is it's a it's great uh
mythology that you should bring up
around you so that you're likable yeah
if he's this old sweet teddy bear that
drinks his Coke on a bench you don't
think of him as this absolutely maniacal
investor that became the richest person
in the world and those things don't work
together like I'm sorry like you don't
make a billion dollars just drinking
cokes on a bench yeah you make a billion
dollars going how can I [ __ ] extract
as much wealth in from every other human
being that's on this planet how can I do
it it's not like he's doing this through
donations
do you know what I'm saying like he's
not giving people access to heaven and
going yeah give me a little bit on the
way in
this is
take Orchard Hathaway I'm gonna take his
company Berkshire Hathaway is a real
estate company they're not like hey
what's the most altruistic way to buy
and sell property they're like hey what
can we buy that's in Ruins and so please
take advantages but do you think he's
like that Hands-On with everything going
on at the company
we're breaking your heart no I just I
just think I think no I think he just
hired the smartest like Ruthless People
he's like oh you're ruthless I'm going
to hire you to make the decisions that I
would make so the ruthless person would
just take his [ __ ] job if he wasn't
ruthless nah it's like he wants to go
sit with a Coke on a bed
you have a business right you have to
work really hard right like you you have
to work really hard you're flying back
and forth your business is successful
and you have to work really hard for
that right yes now think about how much
money your business is is growing right
now think about how hard you have to
work to do that
now think about
billions of dollars
right um
you're about to prove my foot go go go I
would love to hire somebody delegate and
sit on a bench and drink
I would love to do but do you think that
you could do that and grow your business
oh no they're not going to put as much
in it as I would put into it and you
have to put this much in to make the
money you're making now which is good
but is that billions yeah ain't no bench
sitting bro nobody ever sat drank coke
and made billions never once they sat in
rooms with other people who are also
Psychopaths going hey do you think that
those people who can barely afford to
make any money we could sell them uh
trailer homes for uh uh what is it
called we can give them mortgages on
trailer homes and the mortgage rates can
be like five times higher than the
average mortgage rate because they're at
risk I think we could do that like it
sounds like a good idea because these
are crazy people we should do that we
should sounds like an awesome idea
there's the the most brilliant thing
about Warren Buffett this is the most
brilliant thing about him nobody knows
what the [ __ ] he does
well you know he drinks Cokes he loves
McDonald's he loves McDonald's just like
we love Coke and we love McDonald's but
we don't know what he does to [ __ ]
squeeze marginal wealth dog
we don't know he even comes out every
once in a while and says I should be
paying more in taxes do it [ __ ]
ain't nobody stopping you nobody ever
stopped you from paying money in [ __ ]
taxes that [ __ ] is patronizing bro y'all
eat it oh my secretary pay more
[ __ ] taxes are killing you
every single year I should be paying
more in taxes God damn bro God damn pay
the money
for them yeah help me help me you love
doing charity pay other people's taxes
taxes pay our taxes basic flagrant
status that's it there you go I mean
it's crazy that was his big mix-up he
was trying to be goody two shoes with
that one that one I almost
you did not I almost look for the bench
that's how I know he's not the best I
went for it no you did not I looked up
every bench in Omaha remember we did
that show in Omaha in the bar you think
I was there for that show you're a spy I
was there for justice
I'm nice
believe that whole section keep enough
in but make sure you break that whole
thing okay nice I'm just saying it is
that is genius the fact that we don't
know what he's done to make his money
son
close to the bench once a year has
somebody take a picture and they'll be
like I just saw Warren Buffett
in that bench every day hey Bill Gates
how's your PR doing oh it's not good
they think I'm vaccinating everybody you
want to take a bench pick with me come
on down let's take a bench pick together
and the people forget that we out here
squeezing them dry
I mean right or wrong
no I'm not saying completely can't do it
I'm not saying they can't do it but it
is a good lesson to learn which is if
you're going to be worth tons of money
one don't let [ __ ] know how you
make your Goddamn money yeah because
once they find out that it's some other
[ __ ] they're gonna either be resentful
they're gonna hate you they're going to
want to kill you and then two make sure
you have some sort of apparatus to uh
continue to push those narratives yeah
you know that's why you see all these
billionaires got a [ __ ] media company
right Bezos got the Washington Post but
uh what's it called what's his face got
MSNBC Bill Gates
Microsoft NBC yeah right like every
single one of them come on now not the
first time some billionaires that got
caught up in some trouble you seen this
and always say this is wild your boy
Billy Gates walking in front of a hotel
foreign
they pot our boy in the face
it came with the double up oh three oh
yo
he ended up not pressing charges because
uh he believed them to just be like
mischievous pranksters because you can't
press charges because you're a
billionaire
you got to do the good PR thing I'm just
saying hide in the face it's just pie
I'm sorry that was a pretty good price
it's hilarious to be honest you think
you think he set it up for them
we sitting here feeling better
haters
they don't even know they got paid by
him oh it's shell company
Gates and then they figure that [ __ ] out
William over there
100 like the antifa [ __ ] they
don't get paid by some billionaire too
go throw some milkshakes on people where
you get the money for the milkshakes
McDonald's
who's really making the money that
milkshake machine wasn't working dollars
they got that [ __ ] working what happened
immediately afterwards
okay all right that's it I hope one day
you become a millionaire yeah I really
do I really hope you do yeah one day one
day you think that people like me as
much as they do now
[Music]
I'm gonna listen back to this and be
like I know right yeah
this podcast ain't happening if I got
billions
let me tell you something right now I'm
such a billion dollars
if I make a billion dollars
it's by accident
I didn't want it
I don't want it I don't want to put that
out there he's like um
if I make a billion dollars I don't want
it all right I make a million dollars
hey Hollywood don't get me wrong
I just got good it's good hey guys you
got him with a podcast we're doing a
movie in Atlanta I just Hey listen
listen I'm trying to put you all up on
game this is the opposite of the secret
you're the opposite of manifest maybe
that's the
secrets you don't want the billion
dollars if you make a billion dollars
you're giving us half let me tell you
something I make a billion dollars
you're going to give us half if I make a
billion dollars you're gonna give us
that I'm giving the people money
taxes
[Music]
I did not mean to that means he's
setting up Charities and he's giving the
money to his kids
so what about us here on the couch
end up here you got it yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I left an investment somewhere that I
didn't mean to uh and then it made
ability I gifted some crypto for your
wedding or something you're welcome real
time I hey I didn't mean to
hey if there's any billionaires out
there don't give me no billion dollars
No One's Gonna Give him I don't want it
No One's Gonna Give You a pay keep your
money
keep your money no one's trying to give
it to you keep your Goddamn money I
don't want you yeah I want that problem
he'll want it I don't want that problem
what problems billionaire problems bro
like what
son God can't even enjoy a Coke on a
bench Bros
people calling out your actions
everything every little thing
on stage without no jokes no stories
nothing hoping 18 000 people
what the [ __ ] else you were thinking I
love how rich he is what would they clap
for what the [ __ ] like the idea that he
thought that they were just gonna clap
without any entertainment they made
Rockets that's cool
I got a Tesla I love that he built Tesla
electric cars you say with the planet
Andrew he's supposed to that's true he
did not do anything
what do you mean he invented paper I'm
saying in that moment in that moment he
didn't do nothing except you walk on
stage everybody claps you haven't done
anything in that moment you just gotta
make him laugh before so they think they
gonna laugh again
some funny tweets no that's a good
answer he invented Tesla's before and
then they walked out and they're like
he's gonna offend something
son but we're not clapping for that
we clapped because [ __ ] invented
uh electric car yeah yes yeah dude all
right that's a good point figure out
what you're trying to do with yourself
that [ __ ] got hot bro my head was you
like hot but I didn't put any product in
my hair so my hair looked too wispy
today it's the struggles of being a
multi-millionaire
you got to get the pinky
but don't don't try to [ __ ] with me that
business
I make a billion dollars I'ma keep on
giving away a million so I could keep
being a billionaire wait what let me try
it one more time I make a billion
dollars I'm Gonna Keep on giving away a
million so I could just be a regular
millionaire
every time I hit the billion I'm giving
a little away to us
there's some people man but why not
you're already giving it away I'll be
giving you know what I'm gonna give it
to a trust hey that's a noble thing
trust with your trust I trust it I'm
gonna give it to you I trust to trust
I don't trust you but the trust is in
our name
let me tell you something
with a beneficiary
I'll make a billion dollars yep I make
you six feet
oh that's that is kind of yeah
yup yup please give it to him that's
gonna be you son nah nah you can't take
it back
yo son why doesn't he just go why does
he just go yo I'm working on this new
thing to make like people six feet if
they want like he needs to put a couple
he needs to put a couple things of Hope
out there so people aren't willing to
criticize him
um like he thought he was doing that
with traffic in LA
he's like yo we got traffic in L.A taken
care of don't worry about it
I loved it so everyone in L.A is like
okay okay chill out we good whatever
still waiting boom still waiting what is
the thing that he could do for all human
beings
where like if he was like yo we got this
thing it's not it bigger
and trans people would love that too so
you get people on the left also oh [ __ ]
trans people like finally I would love
it great unifier finally everyone gets a
dick free dicks look under your chair
I'm Oprah for dicks there's dicks
everywhere if you're if you're trans you
want a dick you got a dick if you're a
guy you want a bigger dick you got a
bigger dick yo just cut that right
everyone wants them everyone wants that
yo is there a limit to how big these
trans dicks could be because I don't
think it's fair
you can't just come in a game late no
packing you gotta spin the wheel like
all of us bro yo you know how like Oscar
Pistorius his his blades could only be
so long
because it actually gives you an unfair
Advantage yeah they gotta take your
height thanks
dicks can only be so long they have to
look your blade can only be so long body
index or some [ __ ] a million percent
they have to calculate how big how big
your dick would have been and color you
can't just get a black dick nah you
should be able to do that nope why not
tattoos yeah what that's not being black
getting a tattoo is just anxious
[Laughter]
but yeah once you the dick is yours you
should be able to do whatever you want
with it you could dye different colors
you should be able to do it you can dye
your dick 100 you can dye your dick no
you can't yeah yeah you haven't seen
these Indians with their hennas and [ __ ]
isn't that a [ __ ] thing you do on
your wedding day you dip your dick in
heaven
that's how they apply the henna to
everyone else
mainly for the women you know that right
is that again that's mainly for the
women but how do they apply to the
woman's hands the artist dips his dick
in some henna oh do they do it with dick
is that how you apply Hannah yes no no
no no but I got some pencil dick ass
[ __ ]
my only reference is me you might not be
wrong
what are we talking about that's crazy
pencils are long though it's not bad you
know what I mean hey pencils are
effective yeah and you trust them so
studious that's true extremely to get a
job done you're not grabbing like um
like a Sharpie or nothing nope nothing
permanent nobody wants that permanent
marker you working with yeah yeah yo you
got permanent marker bro yeah pencil
think it's nice you make a mistake you
can erase it bang do you have any
mistakes you know what I mean I mean
[Laughter]
all right listen bring it on bro shout
out to Elon though we love you and we do
want to on the podcast